first i want you
tom and jim and the audience to know
that i'm not a skeptic nor a debunker
i'm more of a
i'm curious and i'm clueless
when i research this topic i'm just
baffled and bewildered constantly i
don't know what to think so
when i spoke to travis walton recently
some people thought that i was a skeptic
that's actually not true i i'm asking
detailed questions because i want to
know what was the air like on this alien
ship i want to know what did the glass
rod feel like was it heavy was gravity
the same and so on so if i ask you
detailed questions please it's out of a
place of love
i'm curious to know about skinwalker
but you're asking jim right
i can ask
whoever
and what's its connections to
what's its connection to ufos
uh
well i am by no means an ex expert on
skinwalker ranch uh tom and i know
uh all the people that are involved
george uh calm uh kelleher and george
knapp keller her
uh i've never met mr bigelow i was
supposed to at one point but it never
never happened but um uh there's
i think that that's a fascinating case
uh the
uh i think but i i don't know whether i
can actually discuss that in any kind of
meaningful way because i wasn't there
and i wasn't part of it i read the book
like everybody else i john alexander's a
dear friend of mine and you know he was
there and we talk about it quite a bit
um i think uh what had happened there uh
was true and accurate and real
uh but i also believe that when you go
looking
for the phenomenon
uh it basically doesn't show itself uh
it doesn't like to do that and after 40
years of studying that
you know it's it's that low
observability thing going on you know
why we can never get a good picture of
uap for some strange reason it doesn't
want to go there so you mentioned
earlier you're dazed and confused well
yeah i'm about as dazed as confused as
you are by the whole thing i have my own
opinions based on what i know and based
on what i've read but um
skinwalker is fascinating i i you know
from everybody i know that been there
and done that including
some people that were not mentioned in
the book which i don't want to get into
but uh
it's uh it's a pretty serious place and
a lot of serious things happen there
um
but i'll let tom go
go and talk more about that
sure you know i what i find fascinating
about skinwalker is that um you
basically have the convergence of
multiple
you know
things happening you know so when you
look at ufos you can find stories where
somebody might come out and their cattle
are missing or
there's um
you know a cattle mutilation where blood
is gone or parts of the jar are
dissected maybe an eyeball's gone maybe
the reproductive reproductory organs are
gone or whatever um and a lot of like
really
weird things about it like maybe the
cuts are in between cells maybe there's
no vascular collapse maybe it happened
within 10 minutes when the farmer turned
around or something then you have
people that might have seen lights in
the sky the day the night before when it
happened or you know then there's people
that have paranormal feelings they might
have seen
like you know some type of entity that's
invisible or something they weren't
quite sure then you have poltergeist
events and other houses whatever but
what's weird about skinwalkers they were
all happening there you know so you have
all these things happening in one
location but as jim said it's like
super elusive um it's almost like it'll
watch you be there for a week and then
the night you're driving away to go home
it's like you look at your rear view
mirror and there's something crazy you
know and it almost toys with you that
was something that they all seemed to
say like it seemed like it knew
that you wanted to see something you
want to do something whatever what i
find fascinating is that you have this
one location where so many things are
happening and it's documented by a bunch
of government people a bunch of phd
scientists a bunch of people that have
lived there and um and not only
documented over like a few months we're
talking like decades you know
and it's kind of a hot spot where you
can kind of dig into
trying to find why are they all
happening at this one location and and
what interests me is that i think it
gives us
a potential pathway to discuss some
alternate um
candidates for where they're from or
what they're doing or how it all works
like i think most people like to think
of ufos is they're coming from another
planet you know we found an exoplanet
and it's coming there and how do they
travel well they could do it in 30 years
and they go fast well the data doesn't
seem to suggest that really it it's more
what's happening at skinwalker where it
seems like
it's more about frequencies and
dimensional or
they materialize it's almost like their
displacement craft that displaces our
time like a submarine would in the ocean
um and that was a lot of what dr
halpudoff worked on on atip was
understanding the attributes of the
propulsion and the science that they're
using and i think once you think about
ufos using that kind of a technology
then it's kind of like well if they do
that if they use that that means there's
things that are adjacent to us
that we don't see we don't understand
but are like right here and every once
in a while they can kind of cross over
is it because we're aware of it and can
see it and that opens it or is it
because it's a geomagnetic
area where where those types of things
have an easier time coming through um or
is it everywhere and we just think it's
in one location
i don't know i mean there's a story that
even happened there where they like you
know they were there and they and you're
talking about government
grade phds where they watch
you know something in the atmosphere
open up and something come through not
sure what it is
and and it was a huge event so they run
down to grab the cameras and see what
was on the cameras they open up these
lock boxes and then like all the
electronics are missing and the cameras
and they're like wait what like these
were locked up and who took it's like a
game and so it gets really interesting
where
is it a game i don't know but it might
be a consciousness thing and so
i get passionate about a place like that
because it gives you the ability to do
to really jump into some wild stuff i
mean one of the scientists there
was walking through a field
and they basically saw um you know they
saw they walked past um
like a cow or something and then they
turn around it was gone
and then like 10 minutes later they're
like where is it they turn back around
and there it is on the ground just out
of nowhere with like two broken legs so
they run in the ground
for life
it was no it was alive you know and then
they run back into the the house to go
grab a gun or something to take care of
it and when they come out now it has
four broken legs you know or something
it's like creepy and and and like
causing
alarm because
number one it makes no sense number two
it's like it's happening so quick that
they can't even um and i got family
showing up from the beach you know you
see people behind me but um you
mentioned the beach they all went to the
beach earlier but um
what it seems to be is that it's it's
you know an issue with
time
um and an issue with
moving it like from here to here where
we can't see it and back and then people
see crap and then i don't know it's
it's just wild and it and it's so
fascinating and i always tell people in
hollywood because you know to start
getting into making like
movies and tv series and documentaries
and stuff and i just you don't need to
sensationalize this stuff you don't need
to come up with
um
like like science fiction type um
you know ideas to make it intriguing i
mean it's it is it's it's wild the way
it is you don't have to do much to it